hey guys I am Jessa McDonald it's the
11th of April and here are my top five
favorite stories from the last week in
gaming
first up a bunch of what's dog things
happened and here's everything you need
to know Ubisoft released a trailer in
association with Nvidia to show you just
how cool the game is going to look on PC
although alongside that we got the
recommended system specs which are
pretty damn high check them out and let
me know if you're planning to upgrade
your PC
what chugs will also require you play to
run whether or not you choose to buy
Christine so get old prepped for that
one
next up a five-year-old has essentially
outsmarted the entire market soft tech
division by finding a security flaw in
the Xbox one the adorable little dude
whose name is Christopher earned himself
four free games 50 bucks and a year of
Xbox Live Gold from Microsoft after he
hacked into his dad's account by
entering blank spaces in the
verification screen after entering an
incorrect password instead of rejecting
the input the Xbox one logged into his
death account the preschooler told his
local news station that when he got in
he was like yeah and then got nervous
that his dad would find out are you
smarter than a five year old apparently
not Xbox one development team there's a
pretty awesome Easter egg in battlefield
4 and you'll never guess what it is we
have to move this story along so I'll
just tell you it's a giant shock the
prehistoric Megalodon shock comes from
the battlefield full ocean and my
nightmares in the nancha strike map
within the naval strike dlc youtuber
jack frags found the terrifying creature
and even if you do have a crippling fear
of shocks like me the video is so worth
a watch Microsoft wants to blow your
mind holes with the cloud this week and
he is how the publisher have shown how
they can use the clouds to let
developers offload processing to remote
servers which then frees up local
hardware for rendering and whatnot the
footage we've seen so far is from a
perder type and not the Xbox one but
Microsoft is saying that the cloud can
be used for new kinds of experiences
that have never been possible
and last up the loss of us remastered is
coming to the ps4 and here's all the
good stuff you need to know about it
it's listed at 60 bucks will be in 1080p
and there's already an announcement
trailer to give you your first glimpse
at what we can expect from the updated
visuals graphics wise that will be
high-res character models with improved
textures shadows and lighting as well as
the director's commentary and all the
previously released DLC be sure to let
me know all your thoughts and feelings
on this week's stories and let me know
what you cared about in that commenting
section down below or if you prefer to
hit me up directly i'm on twitter at
just mcdonald this week on site i talked
about whether the Elder Scrolls online
is any good for skyrim fans cam asks
whether MMOs are bad for you and keep up
with Captain America shenanigans in
Skyrim mods those are all the things
that I have for you this week but be
sure to join me again on Monday and I
hope you have a great weekend till then